[Music]
foreign
I have spent my entire career building
developer tools for machine learning and
data science
I have worked at companies like data
robot Airbnb and GitHub
and through all of that experience I've
observed that the most impactful tools
are ones that help you share knowledge
and collaborate with your colleagues
specifically tools that allow you to
publish share and render technical
reports and knowledge in a way that's
easily discoverable that other people
can reference
is something that I have found
personally through my experience to be
the highest impact type of tools that
you can learn and that's why I'm really
excited to teach this course on
enhancing communication and
collaboration with Jupiter notebooks and
quarto so as you may know Jupiter
notebooks is a great medium in which to
write technical information you can
intersperse code and prose in a natural
way without having to copy and paste
code from another context
and you can have inline charts
and interactive widgets and all kinds of
things that really enhance the
presentation of technical material
however how do you go from this Rich
environment of a notebook to publishable
content something like a website or a
blog post or even an internal Knowledge
Management System where if you're
working on a team of data scientists you
can collaborate and and look at each
other's work work and search each
other's work
and this is something that quarto
really excels at
and this is what I want to teach in this
course
so in this course
I'm going to show you how you can author
documents
in both Jupiter notebooks but also in
plain text markdown files
I'll also show you how you can use vs
code in the courtovia success vs code
extension to
Aid you in creating quarter projects and
editing files
I'm going to show you how you can
leverage quarto to create different
types of Publications such as personal
blogs Knowledge Management platforms for
teams
notes books websites and even
presentation slides
these are all formats that I produce
myself with quarto
I'm going to also show you how you can
extend quarto with notebook filters and
extensions
I'm also going to show you how you can
host websites and Publications on
platforms like GitHub Pages quarto Pub
and netlify I'm also going to show you
how you can test your notebooks and test
your documentation so that you can be
sure the code is valid and correct and
is not stale and as a bonus I'm going to
also teach how you can even create and
document python packages within a tool
called nbdev and quarto I am a core
developer on nbdev and nvdev is built on
quarto
in his one of the sources of my
knowledge for core of Corto in one of
the reasons why I am excited about it
I hope that you'll join me in this
course I think
it has a lot of value
for both personal growth in terms of
helping you write blog posts and share
information but also is a great tool
to help you up level your teams
thank you
[Music]